it sure has and yesterday's high
temperature
was only 49 degrees that's the coolest
high temperature we've had since almost
groundhog day
but with sherry off today i'm handling
the weather computer and we start
now with this most accurate weather now
forecast looking at a legion stadium
where
we'll talk about how things didn't go so
well for the raiders
officially it's 41 degrees with light
wind but man we've seen some flags
whipping up in some of the neighborhoods
let's check your temperatures
i believe we have a lot of readings in
the 30s let's check it out
yeah 37 out at the lakes 36 for
mountains edge
kyle canyon is not doing too bad at 31
we do have 41 along the strip
40s in henderson and in green valley
meanwhile as we check outside of town
i don't think this is a fluke i believe
tonopah really does have some whip and
wind and down to 18 degrees
i know one of sherry's favorite viewers
is up there so hopefully she'll let us
know
caliente you're in the upper 20s ely the
low 20s
for the rest of southern nevada and
parts of california there's death valley
at 46.
laughlin 45 now all of these
temperatures believe it or not are
right about normal for this time of year
over in cedar city you guys are right at
the freezing mark
so we're going for a high of 56 today
after that 49 yesterday
if we hit 56 it'll be right smack dab on
the nose of normal we've already been
down to 38 which is also
the normal low for this time of year so
here's what's going on in terms of
clouds
just several more rounds of clouds
coming and going
for most of this week also wanted to
check in on your family and friends
across the rest of the nation
you see some pretty big storms rolling
across the deep south and into the
mid-atlantic states
those are maybe some severe storms over
western tennessee and now moving into
the virginias
nothing like that here our dry streak
continues your seven-day forecast
after 56 today we'll see some sunshine
again tomorrow and 55 breezes might pick
up to 15 miles an hour
upper 50s for clouds and sunshine back
and forth again for wednesday and
thursday
we'll dip a little bit for friday but
there's a chance it will make it back to
60 by the time we get to sunday